[Music]
well I was a skydiver before I was a
computer scientist so I started
skydiving when I turned 18 I wrote my
first computer program probably when I
was 19 so the order is definitely
skydiving then computer science but I
scout out for a very long time I've
obviously worked in the technology field
for a lot for a long time I'd pretty
much given up skydiving at one point and
when I moved out to California in 1984
and didn't make another skydive for a
very long time meanwhile I started
flying airplanes and you know working in
technology companies working on
management and it wasn't till I don't
know maybe six or seven years ago that I
got the bug to skydive again and so for
that I got Reath qualified in skydiving
and then it's a long story but I ended
up deciding to try a stress-free skydive
as well
well the key insight that I think I had
and the team had wasn't trying to build
a capsule I mean a large capsule may be
pressurized to maybe not with lots of
the infrastructure for going up was not
the best way to accomplish what we're
trying to accomplish it was also not
necessarily safest or the cheapest way
and to get in the stratosphere and for
us we wanted to take the analogy of
scuba diving that if you're a scuba
diver you take exactly what you need
with you and nothing else underneath the
water and we wanted to find a stress
ferric equivalent and so that's where we
built scuba diving for the stratosphere
the suit was designed by alcide over and
they built all the Apollo suits they
built all of the extra vehicle activity
suits for you know the you know space
shuttle International Space Station
American astronauts they had a lot of
experience building building spacesuits
the challenge in this case was they were
doing a lot of things that they had
never done before
first they had never worked with a
private citizen on a project they were
used to these very long
government programs that take years and
years even to get and the approval to
move to the next step and here they were
acting like a startup company they had
they built a suit from scratch you know
to deployment and testing you know
probably in a period of a year or two
and that probably is about the same time
that they put in a proposal for
something else it was the first suit
that had been certified from scratch and
put into production in probably 30 years
so it was a big undertaking for them to
do as far as the technology for the suit
and no suit had ever been heated before
it only been cooled this suit was had an
internal frame that was used to support
the the equipment module it had to have
you know thermal connections between it
the suit architecture was very different
because we wanted to make sure that
there was no fogging and we also needed
to guarantee that we would use a minimum
number of a amount of oxygen so normally
these systems flood oxygen by you and so
they don't have to worry about carbon
dioxide but we wanted to use much less
oxygen and we want to eliminate the
possibility that you would end up with
any kind of moisture or freezing on the
faceplate so we had to design an
entirely new architecture and they were
fantastic we had five airplane jumps
where we got used to flying the suit and
ii learned a little bit about how to
control the suit in freefall and we
followed that up by three balloon jumps
first from 57,000 feet a second from one
hundred five thousand feet and the third
was a record jump from one hundred and
thirty five thousand eight hundred
ninety feet the speeds that we acquired
during that jump were
we broke Mach 1 in about 37 seconds of
that freefall and we reached our highest
speed 822 miles an hour in about 51
seconds I mean the problems where the
capsule are you know they're big
complicated they're heavy which requires
a very very large balloon to be able to
lift them and so that because the
balloon so large it actually requires a
different launch to
Niq not to use so by making the system a
lot smaller and a lot lighter what you
could use is a much smaller balloon and
then in turn the smaller balloon allows
you to use a much simpler and I think
safer launch system so at the start we
had a lot going for us the second thing
is the interconnection between the
balloon and the skydiver has caused
issues in the past I mean you know in a
previous attempt for instance somebody
was unable to disconnect the oxygen and
therefore had to ride down with the
balloon and you know there's a harrowing
experience when Joe Kittinger in 1960
tried to get out of his balloon you know
he had trouble getting out of the seed
so there was lots of different issues
associated with capsules and the other
really bad thing about a capsule is if
you're depending on the ship's oxygen
for most of the trip and you're just
going to have what's called a bailout
bottle of oxygen as soon as you
disconnect from that capsule you know
the the time is set you have exactly
maybe 15 minutes to get into a
breathable air or you're gonna die then
the nice piece about a scuba like system
is that I have you know five hours of
oxygen so there's nothing compelling for
me to get out disconnect and get down
right away I have lots of time so if the
parachute opens hi that's not an issue
so there's a lot of safety aspects that
come in to this particular design a lot
of redundancies that came in to this
design to make it you know much safer on
a lot of different dimensions how do you
look at a problem area and try to
understand whether the approach that's
always been taken is the right one or
not and I think the biggest thing for me
is you kind of try to go back to first
principles what is the problem that
you're trying to solve and don't look at
every other solution in that space but
look at solutions in other spaces around
it and try to figure out parallels so in
my case what I wanted to do is be able
to explore the stratosphere I wanted to
be up in the stratosphere and I wanted
to be able to do anything once I'm in
the stress
so a capsule idea doesn't really get you
it's hard to get the capsule in
stratosphere it's complicated but the
the main issue is it doesn't allow me to
do anything that I'd want in the
stratosphere so let's say I want to take
a balloon trip and then come back down
with a balloon well if I build a capsule
then I have to have a whole different
capsule designed for going up and coming
down or let's say I all of a sudden
decided I wanted to go up in a sail
plane you know there's some fabulous
efforts right now to see if you can use
you know around the Andes and even in
South America these polar lifts that
they think might be able to allow sail
plane to get up to maybe a hundred
thousand feet so if you've got this
capsule well now I want to use a sail
plane right so I have to start over
because I have to combine building an
aircraft and a life-support system
but let's imagine separating those two
let's say I'm just gonna build a
life-support system then I could
conceivably just go into any sail plane
and be able to do that so you know the
key for me is step away from it look at
the problem you're trying to solve and
then start looking at all the possible
solutions for that class a problem in
all the domains that are rounded and if
you do that you'll often find insights
to make the problem that used to be
incredibly complex and incredibly
expensive you can find a different
approach that might be a lot cheaper you
know might be a lot easier might be a
lot safer might cost a lot less but you
know the issue is when you first come up
with it people are gonna kind of think
you're crazy because the first the first
time you ever think about something in a
totally new domain the initial reaction
is always going to be negative not
because the people don't love you not
because they don't care about you
but because nobody's seen this problem
in that dimension and they'll continue
for a while and then there's this moment
which I love which is when something
goes from the impossible and it will
quickly go to the inevitable and so it's
that moment of impossible to inevitable
in many technologies that swap happens
not over 20 years but over a month and
that's what excites me
[Music]